il
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est quoi être un homme depuis toujours
une question que je me pose qui me
taraude
c'est quoi être un homme quand j'étais
enfant j'avais la profonde sensation que
le monde dans lequel j'étais n'est pas
ajusté quelque chose n'était pas à sa
place
aujourd'hui encore quand j'entends les
cris des femmes
les pleurs des enfants les hommes qui
s'entretuent je vois je me dis pourquoi
et si je me dis pourquoi parce qu'au
fond de moi j'ai encore ce rêve
ce rêve d'enfant d'un monde où on peut
vivre ensemble unis en paix et en
harmonie et si vous êtes là ce soir
probablement que c'est que vous avez
encore peut-être un peu ce rêve
j'ai peut-être choquer mais la question
de l'égalité pour moi n'est pas le sujet
le sujet n'est pas l'égalité et
lorsqu'on entend ce débat sur l'égalité
hommes femmes
j'ai toujours surpris de voir en fait
que le mot qui est le plus important
dans ce débat c'est le mot égalité
or il ya deux autres mots hommes et
femmes
si à deux mots différents s'est
peut-être qu'il ya une certaine
différence non alors j'aurais pu lui
répondre à la question c'est quoi être
une femme vous avouerai que de là où je
suis pas sûr qu on croyait alors je vais
tenter non pas de donner une réponse
mais de partager ses réflexions qui
m'habite
peut-être qu'en partageant
collectivement on pourra avancer
je crois que on ne naît pas homme je
crois qu'on le devient je crois qu'on le
devient par le travail et par un chemin
chemin parfois long et j'ai cheminé
pendant des années j'ai cheminé avec
cette question c'est quoi être un homme
j'ai cheminé sur tous les continents à
la rencontre d'hommes et de femmes qu'on
appelle d éveiller des maîtres
spirituels les chamans jerry j'ai pleuré
j'ai eu peur j'ai crié j'ai traversé des
zones de lumière des zones de noir
intense de tous ces voyages j'ai retenu
une seule chose essentielle pour moi
c'est finalement le chemin c'est pas
fait pour aller plus loin au contraire
c'est fait pour aller plus près alors
oui on devient un homme au fur et à
mesure du temps et il ya plusieurs
étapes
plusieurs passages pour ça le premier à
20 ans on commence à construire sa
structure à 30 ans l'homme qu'on
commence à construire son foyer puis à
40 ans il a commencé à construire cette
situation est à 50 ans l'a commencée
l'âge la transmission et à 60 70 ans la
préparation pour dernier passage il ya
un passage qui est le plus délicat
d'entre tous le plus difficile le plus
déterminant c'est le premier ce passage
de ce qui précède l'homme à l'homme
qu'est ce qui précède l'homme assez le
garçon il ya une différence entre hommes
et garçons ça vous pouvez poser la
question à toutes les femmes
quelle est la différence avant tout vous
dire c'est pas pareil
non c'est pas pareil c'est un changement
radical
je mange changement radical qui est
difficile douloureux certains mettent
plus ou moins de temps à le passer
françoise dolto appelé ça le complexe du
homard pourquoi le complexe du homard
parce que le homard en fait pour grandir
pour devenir adulte
mais il doit perdre sa carapace père
dans sa carapace il dit à un vule les
râbles à tous les prédateurs
en fragilité mais le garçon monde passer
à l'état d'homme c'est exactement ça il
doit perdre sa carapace et sa carapace
est quoi mais la carapace c'est le cocon
maternel la matrice maternelle qui
sécurise et qui protège et donc le jeune
garçon qui doit devenir homme est face à
un dilemme sécurité protection ou
liberté difficile alors certains garçons
parfois refuser l'obstacle ne savent pas
où sont pas accompagnés parce que ça
demande à être accompagnés j'en parlerai
après et donc est ce qu'il va se passer
bien ce qui va se passer c'est qu'ils
vont devenir en fait des garçons adultes
alors c'est quoi un garçon adultes bas
un garçon adultes
ça ressemble à un homme sale goût de
l'homme ça sent l'homme connaissez la
suite
six passagers pas fait le garçon a gardé
sa carapace et cette carapace à
apprendre plein de formes elle va se
sophistiquer elle va se renforcer
ça va être des stratégies qui vont
utiliser essentiellement la force ou
l'intellect utilisant la force et
l'intellect va s'inscrire en fait une
logique de domination de puissance
je vous faire une confidence toutes les
démonstrations de puissance auquel on
assiste à l'extérieur sont simplement un
aveu d'impuissance et donc ce garçon 20
avancer dans la vie avec cette
souffrance
pourquoi cette souffrance parce qu'en
fait à l'intérieur il ya une dimension
qui crie qui est enfermé et qui
n'arrivent pas à sortir comme si on
avait les ailes coupées
et comme si en fait une partie nous ne
pouvait pas s'exprimer
c'est quoi cette partie c'est parti
c'est la partie féminine en soit on a
les deux polarités
je crois que notre monde en fait en
occident et la planète entière
maintenant souffrent de ces hommes
garçons qui n'ont pas encore
complètement fait ce passage est
pourquoi si je prends la lignée
paternelle de mon côté j'ai un
arrière-grand-père qui a fait 14 18
quand mon grand père était enfant il n'a
pas vu son grand sociaux son père j'ai
un grand père qui a été pris en 39-40
dans la guerre est venue de captivité en
45 mon père qui est né en 38 n'a vu son
père qu'à 8 en sept ans et ainsi de
suite
et ça c'est l'histoire en fait de la
planète où depuis si longtemps on a des
guerres et les hommes n'ont pas eu en
fait l'initiation masculine qui se
devait parce qu'il s'agit bien
d'initiation et passage masculin du
garçon à l'homme dans toutes les grandes
traditions il a ses rites initiatiques
dans toutes les traditions il existe six
rites initiatiques ils ont quel but
ils ont le but en fait d'aider ce
passage de la traversée des peurs on a
quatre grande peur la peur de la mort ou
la peur d'exister ça va ensemble
ça me rappelle un chaman qui misait avec
son accent chilien leur allant vous
savez là la vie est une aventure dont
vous ne sortirez pas vivant et puis à la
peur de la folie ou la perte de sens il
ya la peur de la liberté et la peur de
l'isolément les rites initiatiques de
passage sont là pour faire traverser les
peurs et si on traverse pas les peurs
alors on reste toute sa vie traversée
par les peurs on en a tous mais elle
nous traversent plus ou moins fortement
et aujourd'hui on est dans un monde en
fait
traversé par les peurs allumez la télé
la radio regarder partout on est en fait
dans un monde nourrit d'anxiété et on se
nourrit de ça parce que ça qu'on a
appris
et donc cette souffrance de l'homme on
parle de la souffrance de la femme mais
il ya une vraie souffrance de l'homme
qui parfois ne le sait même pas cette
souffrance de l'homme
elle est liée à ce manque de passage ce
manque de rite initiatique qui a pour
but en fait d'harmoniser à l'intérieur
le masculin et le féminin et donc je
crois que le sujet n'est pas du tout
légalité le sujet et la complémentarité
alors la complémentarité s'est pas tu
cuisines et je mange non la
complémentarité
c'est l'association des polarités qui
vont générer la vie on est au service de
la vie la vie nous transperce
on est au service de la vie et donc
c'est ça la complémentarité on la
retrouve dans toutes les grandes
symbolique initiatique
regardez le vase et l' inverse
ça fait l'étoile de david regardez le
ying et le yang le noir contient le
blanc et le blanc contient le noir
garder la croix chrétienne la
verticalité et l'horizontalité qui est
féminin à la verticalité qui est là le
jugement la façon de 2,2 de tranchées où
l'action voilà et donc on souffre de son
manque de complémentarité c'est dans la
complémentarité et la complémentarité
elle est d'abord à l'intérieur tout ce
que l'on voit à l'extérieur n'est qu'une
projection notre intérieur et donc je
crois que l'enjeu en fait est de trouver
cette harmonie cette paix à l'intérieur
aujourd'hui j'ai deux garçons de 20 et
21 ans ils sont exactement à cet âge-là
du passage et mon rôle est d accompagner
alors pour répondre à la question c'est
quoi être un homme je pourrais juste
dire que je me sens un homme je suis un
homme quand je peux me montrer
vulnérable quand je peux être la face à
vous quand je peux accepter d'être
détesté travail et mes sens que ça
change rien pour moi je suis un homme
quand je sais dire je jeu c'est un homme
quand je suis un homme quand je sers
renoncer renoncer c'est aussi se
prononcer je sais je suis un homme quand
je m'engage et quand je suis intègre
sadia quand je fais ce que je dis et je
dis ce que je fais et je suis un homme
quand je partage avec vous ce rêve
d'unité
parce que je crois que profondément le
portent tous et on le porte tous et on a
tous envie de vivre dans ce ensemble
j'ai envie de finir en disant mithaq
houllier ou yacine muta couillaud yacine
en indien lakota ça veut dire nous
sommes tous reliés
nous sommes tous unis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]